for those that don't know you or know
your background maybe give us kind of a
quick one minute just on your journey um
in applied cryptography and how you got
involved in bitcoin
um
so i guess i was in some ways like super
early and then kind of came and went a
couple of times so
i uh
in the
mid to late 90s i was involved in the
cyberpunks list and cryptography for
things like tor like anonymous remailers
privacy for browsing and electronic
cache so i had implemented some of the
crypto libraries for digi cache
kind of centralized but very anonymous
electronic cache system
and then i came to invent hashcash as a
kind of postage stamp to
make it more difficult for people to
spam
sending emails and discussion forum
posts through
three mailers and uh usually you do that
with
identity just blacklist ip addresses and
email addresses but you can't do that
when the sender is anonymous so that was
kind of what caused me to think about
what's the real problem here it's free
let's suppose it cost
credit cards are difficult
but we can do proof of work
and that started a kind of multi-year
discussion well probably decade plus
discussion about how to make a
responsible electronic cash
and kind of involved you know how finney
next arbor we die and things like be
money and big gold which is some of the
bitcoin
precursors so that was a kind of early
involvement and then i think i was the
first person to get
an email from statistician at komoto
sometime in late 2008 uh asking about
hashcash citation and so i exchanged a
few emails with him
and so when you first get that email
like why does he email you he she they
and what was kind of your reaction or
what did you think
uh so
the question originally was you know i'm
i'm developing an electronic cash system
i'm citing and using your
paper on hash cash
how how should i cite it because it
wasn't an academic publication it was a
kind of research report not my personal
website right so how to fight her is a
little
yeah you know it's not a reference to a
journal and a date kind of thing
and
so
uh let me exchange some more emails
later about other related uh electronic
cash systems so what i thought about it
well
you know if you've got some open source
software or applied crypto publications
online from time to time you get
you know developers and people doing
other applied research
just email you out the blue and ask your
questions or send you links to what
they're working on
cvo ideas for feedback that kind of
thing so it didn't occur to me the
station accumulated was a student
actually at the time so
and obviously you know i was somebody
who'd been
interested in electronic cache for a
long time i thought it was
pretty interesting but
you know at that stage it's open
question
i guess to everybody about whether this
would actually boost wrap right so i
think that was what makes there was no
exchanges in the early days and just
kind of you know people mining starting
to
trade things
for bitcoin like pizzas
[Music]
today today an enormous amount of
bitcoin and things like that so it took
some years till that you know until i
think you know there were different
targets like a dollar or a hundred
dollars and people would think well
actually maybe it is going to take off
you know it's unclear as a hobbyist kind
of technologist interest type of thing
whether that would destroy a stable
value and reach kind of take off energy
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]